-One of my favorite couples is
Amy Schumer and Chris Fischer.
He is a great chef.
She is a fantastic comedian,
writer, and actor.
During isolation, they're making
a new Food Network show
where Chris teaches Amy
how to cook, and it's very fun
Here's my conversation wit
Amy Schumer and Chris Fischer.
I am so happy
that you guys are here.
Amy, you have been
on my show before.
Chris, this is your first time
but we've actually known
each other for a very long time.
You've known my wife
even longer.
So I'm going to ask you
three things,
and you tell me which one
of these things is not true.
You cooked at my wedding
barefoot...
we shared custody
of a goat named Raisin...
you wore Birkenstocks
to my wife's bat mitzvah.
-I'm going to go with --
Can I answer?
And I think that it's "D" --
all of the above are true.
-Every one of those things is
true thing about your husband.
-That is all highly unsettling
Well, Chris just told me, like
the origin of the goat
and why it's a rescue goat
-Yeah.
-The Ashe family rescued Raisi
from me because
I was going eat him.
-Alexi's family -- Chris was
planning on eating the goat.
-Yeah.
-Because something that I've
learned about is that goat
is the most highly consumed meat
in the world, right?
-That's true.
-Sorry.
I know so much about food now,
but he was going to
eat that goat.
But then you guys
rescued Raisin the goat.
-I had nothing to do with it
I would have been far happie
if Chris had eaten that goat
[ Laughter ]
But my father-in-law did
fall in love with that goat,
and then Raisin was a family
goat for almost a decade.
-Yeah, it's alarming.
I'm so happy.
-He is no longer with us,
Raisin.
No longer with us. He escaped.
-We just want to say,
we are so sorry for your loss.
-[ Laughs ] Thank you.
But not a day goes by
that I don't think about it.
How are -- Now,
you guys are out of New York
You're isolating together.
How is it going?
-Um, you know, I think it's --
We do our best to avoid
each other all day, but --
like most couples --
But, no, it's -- You know,
New York, it was like --
It was tough being in New York
and Chris became a liability
Because, you know,
we would have, like, a pep tal
before we would leave.
It would be like, "Okay,
we're about to go outside.
Masks, gloves.
We're not going to touch."
And then we'd get...
And then we'd get
in the elevator,
and Chris would
just, like, bare-hand,
like, -- boop! Lobby.
And, like, lean against
the door. I'm like, "What --
And then we're walking outside
and he's like --
I'm like, "That was 3 feet!"
-There was a running commentar
of the distance
between me and other people.
-"Oh, wait! That was 6 inches!
So we got out of New York
mostly because, like,
we were the problem
and Chris was a liability.
-Yeah. You're spending tim
with your beautiful boy, Gene,
who's 11 months old.
-No. What a bad friend.
-Wow.
-Did he turn one?
-Yeah.
You know, we didn't actually
get your birthday text or gift
which is weird.
-No, I only want to give mysel
credit because --
I'm a good friend because
I did watch the first episod
of your show,
and you guys talk at lengt
about how he's 11 months old
-Okay.
-He's from live television
-Yeah, Seth, there's something
other than live television
I know you don't know that
But there's a whole other worl
out there.
-I just have never seen
a pair of parents
who are prouder that their kid
was 11 months old,
'cause you mentioned it
a whole lot.
-Yeah.
-Really? Eww.
-It was our first show.
-It was your first show.
This is -- So, Chris,
you are a talented chef.
Amy, you do not know
how to cook.
And this is a genuinely,
genuinely fun show to watch.
It's very low-fi. You are
filming it during isolation.
And how did you
come up with the idea,
and are you enjoying making it
-Okay.
That's very good questions
We did not
come up with the idea.
Food Network approached us
-Oh, wow.
-And we were like,
"You know what?
We are tech avail.
We are available right now."
We were like, "That sounds cool.
Like, let's do it."
We want something to focus on.
We don't do well with idle time.
-I think also, like,
I would have a terrible
cooking show by myself.
Amy, as you mentioned,
doesn't know how to cook.
So it has to -- You know,
it has to be our strong suits.
And so --
-Yeah.
-You know, you add
a lot of great commentary
and beautiful beverages.
-And I'm not --
I'm pretty easy on the eyes.
-That's true.
-All of this is true.
I think, like a great marriage
you complement each other
very well.
-Yeah.
-We did mention that your son,
Gene, makes a few appearances.
Gene, who's over a year old.
-Thank you, good friend.
Former best friend.
-Gene -- I did know that Gen
had to recently
have a name change.
Can you explain this real quick?
-Oh, we just thought
it would be a better name.
What do you mean?
His middle name -- We just
thought we'd honor my father
Yeah, I mean, by accident,
we named our son Genital.
I mean, look,
a lot of people go through this.
-So you're --
You named him after the
great comedian Dave Attell
His middle name was Attell
And it took you a full yea
to realize that Gene Attel
was "Genital."
-No, we realized it
about a month in,
and to say I was alarmed
is a pretty big understatement
You know, after you have a baby,
like, a month in, you're
not vulnerable or anything
so that's a cool time to realize
that you named your son after,
you know, the section wher
their penis is and vagina is
It's great.
-[ Laughs ]
-No, but we just
officially changed it and --
Yeah, I mean, but to fail that
hard right out the gate.
I think you texted me
a couple of times
because I think you were
really delighted by it.
-I mean, it was -- But also --
And also, like, Fischer.
Last name Fischer
could be "Fissure."
-You caught that, did you?
You did catch that.
Yes, that is true.
-Like, both sides of the Attel
did not make it better.
-I mean, are you proud of ever
moment of your life, Seth?
-I also want to talk about this,
which is very exciting.
Amy, you had a fantastic
stand-up special
while you were pregnant
with Gene.
-Yes, I did.
-But I also know that was
also a difficult pregnancy
-It was a difficult pregnancy.
-And now you also --
You're making a documentar
about that whole process.
Oh, you both look so good.
I also should note
my favorite thing
and the most Chris thing about
the first episode of your show
was that the way Chris
gets his hair ready
is just putting olive oil in it.
So if you guys are watchin
at home right now saying, like
"Hey, salons are closed.
How does that guy look so good?"
-Well, actually I have been, you
know, cutting everybody's hair
and I'm actually
pretty proud of it.
I gave myself this,
even though nobody --
I mean, now that
I'm seeing it on camera --
Wait. Look at it on camera
It's like real --
-Oh, yeah, it's way out.
-I thought that was intentional.
-No it's not --
Why would that be intentional?
-It's the Rachel.
-No, it's not the Rachel.
Look at this.
-Can you lean?
Can you lean this way and we'l
flatten it? There you go.
-Okay.
-That's perfect.
[ Laughter ]
Wait. So you have a documentar
called "Expecting Amy."
What can we -- What can we -
I was going to say,
what can we expect from that
Oh, there you go. Nice.
Clean it up.
-So, well, first of all,
we documented the pregnancy,
and making a special --
I loved Jerry Seinfeld's
"Comedian" --
-Yes, great film.
-...creating his special.
And so it's kind of like tha
if he had been pregnant.
And we don't know
that he wasn't, actually.
-That's true. Alexander Hammer
-Alexander Hammer. Yeah. H
directed it and is editing it.
He edited Beyoncé's
"Homecoming."
And he really is, like,
creating it and shaping it
And we're really proud of it
and we hope people like it
-I can't wait to see that.
I can't -- Look at that.
Just cleaning it up.
Just on a very high
professional level.
-He's always been...
-And, hey, tell Gene
happy 11-month birthday.
-You'll never see him again.
We were gonna make you
the godfather.
-Love you, guys.
-Love you. Bye. Thank you.
-Thank you.